what's going on reject nation so put out
a poll a little bit ago about covering
two videos and this is one of them
so it's gonna be about evil captain
america in doctor strange
two possibly fighting with scarlet witch
i saw a headline for this pop-up late
last night and you know we all know that
captain america and marcus evans is in
talks to return right now to the mcu
supposedly for
at least two more movies if i'm not
mistaken but i'm interested to hear what
cosmic wonder her good
and by the way i just want to say thank
you to warren warren's actually a really
good friend of mine just last week i was
on the phone with him for
for an hour called him out of the blue
he's a really great guy he
like you know out all talk outside of
videos and whatever he's
genuinely a really good person and i
love i'll just love the fact that he's
in my life so
warren thank you for being a friend and
let's see what you got to say
you freaking fraud
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and right now all the hype in the
mcu is about
two different projects of course
spider-man 3 because of all
of the reports and rumors attached to it
but also of course
one division because we just had the
release of the first two episodes last
reaction tomorrow tomorrow slash tonight
at 1 am pacific time and what's really
cool about the hype around these two
projects is
they're actually going to connect to
each other one division is going to tie
heavily into what happens in spider-man
3 and from there
the events of one division and
spider-man 3 are going to tie into
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness yes and this has actually been
confirmed by none other than the marvel
studios president kevin feige
now we've known for a while that want a
vision would tie into doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness elizabeth
olsen was even shooting scenes for
doctor strange 2 before production for
the movie got put on hold due to coven
19. so we knew that but then kevin feige
during the investor day said that
spider-man 3 is going to connect with
one division and doctor strange 2.
and now we have a new report about
something really cool that could happen
in doctor strange in the multiplayer
let's hear this
this is coming from daniel richmond's
patreon where he says
doctor strange will fight two avengers
in multiverse of madness the scarlet
witch and
an evil version of captain america
he also says that kevin feige wants
jennifer lawrence's mystique
in the movie as well not sure about
mystique that could be used for many
different things and multiverse of
madness but let's talk about the scarlet
witch and an evil captain america taking
on doctor strange
now there have been a lot of suspicions
that the scarlet witch would be evil by
the end of one division
and paul bettany did reveal that towards
the end of one division there is going
to be
a huge battle that's going to have more
cgi
than avengers end game think about that
for a second more cgi's
than avengers end game that means these
battles are going to be
absolutely insane wait we gotta admit it
we gotta we gotta slow this down for a
second here we go
there's a lot of information to handle
right here okay there's a lot of
information to handle right here
episode eight cost a billion dollars all
right
so first order of business doctor
strange fighting two
avengers in this movie who have both
gone to the evil side now if you were to
tell me
that it's wanda for sure he's gonna be
fighting i'm like well
actually yeah that makes a lot of sense
just off of the first two episodes alone
you kind of get the vibe that juan is
headed down a very dark path and
possibly going into evil scarlet witch
terrain right so it would make sense
that he's gonna fight
this version of wanda but then to get
evil captain america in here if that's
like your
your returns i heard a rumor that you
might see a version where captain
america fights wolverine
in like a earlier era like much earlier
logan era
but to get evil cap in here that would
be so cool because
it makes me think about how everyone was
excited when he did the hail hydra line
in avengers end game it was like a
clever line and he was you know
pretending to be with hydra
a lot of people were thinking could this
also be an easter egg to evil cap
that'd be neat i don't know about any
mystique in here i feel like jennifer
lawrence got bored of that character
really fast i feel like they've also had
to pay a few people
way more than normal to get them back in
this cameras the amount you would have
to pay her to sit through that makeup
again i think would be
way too much it'd be way too much i
highly doubt you want to do it i'm kind
of curious to know why
feige would be actually courting her to
be
in this film she seemed like not a
likely candidate to be in
in doctor strange multiverse of madness
but in terms of getting evil cap and
wanda i think that would be very
exciting that'd be
really exciting stuff well and that's
probably the coolest prospect
to bring chris evans back after he kind
of retired in a pretty official seeming
way to bring him back as like the flip
side villain conversion would actually
be super exciting and i imagine a pretty
exciting opportunity for
him and then to revealing i mean i'm
surprised paul bettany put this out
there
especially because of the fact that the
first two episodes of one division have
no action and it doesn't count the match
it doesn't seem like it was headed
towards a big battle i imagine there
would be a couple of action scenes here
or there eventually
but it the last vibe i got was that
they'd be going to some like
major battle event but if they're headed
down that path and if
more cgi than end game like what the
hell how would you possibly pull that
off
are you bringing in the x-men everyone's
going to be
just every character on the screen it
seems kind of a big leap i'm i'm kind of
wondering if paul bettany's even a
hundred percent about that at this point
i want to know i think he's just saying
that because he wasn't in the battle at
end game
so uh technically i'm one more person
who's here so
more all right let's continue this wow a
lot of information in one minute
are going to be absolutely insane and
they're most likely going to
involve a lot of magic so whoever wanda
is going to be fighting has to be
extremely strong because she is already
most likely one of the most powerful
characters in the mcu if not the
strongest and most of you know my theory
by now i think mephisto is the main
villain and i also think that agatha
harkness is a villain as well
two characters who are highly
well-versed in witchcraft
and if these are the two characters that
she will be fighting at the end of one
division there is a good chance that yes
she could turn evil
and maybe not even turning evil but just
not caring anymore
so perhaps she goes about doing things
her own way from then on out that's a
good way to put it true
problem with that now as for an evil
captain america we did get reports last
week
stating that chris evans could return to
the mcu in fact they said that he's in
final negotiations to return
for two different movies where he won't
be the lead it will more likely be
cameos and this will certainly be a very
interesting cameo
an evil captain america fighting doctor
strange
now i feel like if it wouldn't be a
cameo i think it would be more of a
supporting role yeah i don't think he
would
be returned just for a cameo i feel like
it'd be a supporting role
that's that's all i wanted to say yeah
multiverse of madness anything
is possible an evil captain america is
possible especially if you consider the
fact that by the end of one division
wanda will most likely have figured out
how her reality warping powers work
so it probably won't be that hard for
her to create a reality where an evil
captain america exists
and then bring him into the normal real
reality
and then it'll be up to doctor strange
to send him back so this will most
likely happen
that's a good theory that's a good
theory a lot of characters that we see
that don't belong to
our actual timeline but other timelines
and other universes
this is why the multiverse will be and
madness in doctor strange too because of
what happened in one division and then
of course
in spider-man 3. based off of all of the
reports and rumors that we heard
spider-man 3 is going to consist of
characters from at least
three different universes and the reason
they could be all colliding into one
universe is because of the events that
will happen in one division
it looks like wanda could be creating
multiple different realities and then
fusing some together whether on purpose
or not now i don't think it'll be on
purpose
quick cameo from chris evans if he does
indeed appear in multiverse of madness
there's not really much he can do to
fight against doctor strange i think the
madness means just way more powerful
but perhaps if the scarlet witch gives
him a little bit of magic maybe he might
actually be a problem
but do you think the scarlet witch will
be evil in multiverse of madness yes if
i hear anything else i'll let you know
so be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest mcu news
be sure to give the video a like and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you
so much for watching woof woof thanks
warren yeah i mean i think wanda will
undoubtedly be
the darker version of herself she will
be the evil scarlet witch
more represented in stuff like house of
m yeah i i undoubtedly think that i
think the last thing i'd say is that
all this talk that we were thinking
about multiverse of madness opening up
the door
i didn't even think about how maybe the
finale of wanda vision
will be that tease where whatever crazy
big battle that
paul bettany is teasing that's when
we'll see the crazy plethora of
characters
just all showing up mephisto's hell just
unleashes
ghost riders and motorcycling boxes yeah
dude the greatest hits of every possible
character they can throw out
and then it's up to us to break it all
down and go okay so all 120 of these
characters
may appear over the next 10 faces he
said more cgi
than end game didn't say more characters
that's the key though
i don't know man there's a lot of
exciting information here and more now
i'm even more pumped for
how wanda vision is going to i just love
the idea of making
potentially a huge antagonistic force
out of one of our heroes
that's a new evil cap coming oh that'd
be very exciting
all right guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that
notification bell thank you more for
putting this video together make sure to
subscribe to cosmic wonder if you
haven't done so already
catch you guys soon